sí
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález la
revolucionaria isla de cuba es el
escenario de una serie de
manifestaciones ciudadanas como nunca
antes había visto ese país socialista la
profunda crisis económica la escasez la
crisis sanitaria causada por la pandemia
de kobe 19 la falta de libertades y
oportunidades hicieron despertar el
descontento de los cubanos que quieren
cambios y quieren soluciones
contundentes que han hecho temblar al
sistema socialista impuesto por los
castros hace ya 60 años desde el
gobierno liderado por el presidente
miguel díaz canel indicaron que habrá
una respuesta revolucionaria sumada
también a la intimidación por parte de
las fuerzas de seguridad cubanas que han
reprimido estas marchas así es como
están las cosas veamos
al grito de libertad y abajo la
dictadura miles de cubanos salieron a
las calles de varias ciudades del país
en una de las mayores manifestaciones en
contra del gobierno cubano rechazó su
gestión de la pandemia de kobe 19 la
escasez de alimentos medicinas o los
apagones de luz diarios como vivo por la
represión que hay con el pueblo que nos
tiene matando no de hambre
ya estamos en casa las protestas
estallaron de forma pacífica en el
municipio de san antonio de los baños
pero se replicaron tanto en la capital
la habana como en el exterior con el
apoyo de la comunidad cubana en el
exilio la policía cubana intentó repeler
las manifestaciones por la fuerza con
violentos choques entre los
manifestantes y los pro gobierno que
dejaron varios heridos pueblo salió al
press al ser libremente y están
reprimiendo y dando respuesta a la
inédita ola de manifestaciones en su
contra el líder del partido comunista
existo a sus partidarios a tomarse las
calles listos para el combate
militarizando las calles de la capital
donde se produjeron también apagones de
internet y telefonía móvil vamos a
admitir que ningún contrarrevolucionario
mercenario
bendigo al gobierno de los eeuu vendidos
al imperio recibiendo dinero de las
agencias vayan a provocar
desestabilización en nuestro pueblo y
habrá una respuesta revolucionario y por
eso también aquí estamos convocando a
todos los revolucionarios del país
a todos los comunistas a que salgan a
las calles en cualquiera de los lugares
donde se van a producir estas
provocaciones el inédito estallido
social en cuba- llega en un momento de
fuerte crisis social y económica en la
isla agravada en parte por las sanciones
de eeuu y la emergencia sanitaria bueno
con este panorama el gobierno cubano ha
dicho que muchas de estas marchas
también han sido gestadas desde las
redes sociales y que también una de las
causas de la situación que está
atravesando cuba es debido a ese embargo
que washington ha impuesto a la isla
hace ya muchas décadas atrás también ha
dicho desde la habana o han dicho desde
la habana que esta inestabilidad en
gestada desde eeuu lo veíamos en
palabras del presidente díaz canel
efectivamente por el gobierno de eeuu y
también por el exilio cubano que está
afincado en el estado de florida pero
desde la casa blanca ha negado tener
algo que ver con todo este asunto que se
está viviendo en la isla veamos
y volví
este sería un grave error que el régimen
cubano interprete que lo que está
ocurriendo en decenas de pueblos y
ciudades en toda la isla es el resultado
o producto de algo que eeuu haya hecho
en cuestión
esta sería un grave error porque
demostraría que ellos simplemente no
están escuchando las voces del pueblo
cubano de moisés en web
afectivamente
un pueblo profundamente profundamente
cansado de una represión que ha durado
demasiado tiempo para analizar este tema
está con nosotros maría werlau ella es
analista y directora ejecutiva de
archivo cuba se encuentra en la ciudad
de san juan en puerto rico y también
está con nosotros maría fernanda barreto
ella se escritora y analista es
especializada en temas de geopolítica
latinoamericana también es feminista y
defensora de los derechos humanos ella
se encuentra en la ciudad de caracas en
venezuela ustedes también nuestros
televidentes son parte de esta
conversación a través de las redes
sociales ustedes pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas en nuestras
cuentas en facebook y en twitter también
en instagram estamos como arroba
france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
pueden dejar sus comentarios con el
numeral el debate efe 24 en este momento
hay una encuesta en línea que el área de
internet de france 24 ha puesto allí
para que ustedes dejen su opinión y
participen deben responder a la pregunta
qué opinan del estallido social que se
está presentando en cuba ya esperamos
todas sus respuestas y sus
pues comienza entonces con maría verla
en la ciudad de san juan en puerto rico-
preguntándole en maría si estas marchas
son sin duda un punto de quiebre en la
historia cubana qué significan estas
manifestaciones para el pueblo cubano
mira y eso que esto es muy popular yo
que nunca pasado en la historia de la
revolución porque tengo un juego que
lleva 62 años por un aparato de festivo
donde el miedo se ha institucionalizado
o sea ya este gobierno no tenía que
fusilar masivamente como en los primeros
años o encarcelar decenas de miles que
es como un cáncer a varios miles al año
y tener el aparato de vigilancia era
suficiente para mantener el control y
para mantener el miedo en el pueblo pero
fue un estallido que al ver las personas
que se manifestaban abiertamente y sin
miedo
soy un chico muy significativo
la perdimos ahí unos segundos pero
mantenemos la conexión con usted paso
ahora a hacerle la misma pregunta para
abrir el debate a maría fernanda barreto
en caracas en venezuela sí este es un
punto de quiebre para los cubanos y el
significado que tienen estas
manifestaciones adelante
santiago un gusto saludarte un gusto
saludar a la audiencia de tu programa y
bueno decir que por cierto está en el
mapa correcta venezuela
el mapa correcta venezolana incluir el
territorio esequibo
bueno lo que está pasando en cuba en
estos momentos es justamente tal como lo
hemos venido denunciando no solamente
las autoridades del país cubano sino
también desde el pueblo cubano y desde
también las cancillerías de otros países
un nuevo intento de los eeuu en este
contexto geopolítico mundial en el que
se encuentra en clara crisis hegemonía
mundial un nuevo intento por realizar en
cuba- una revolución de colores que es
una modalidad digamos aplicando la
modalidad de garra híbrida contra la
revolución cubana
y ocupando también esa misma cualidad
contra venezuela y contra los países que
no están subordinados a sus intereses en
la región de modo tal que ciertamente ha
habido protestas en algunos lugares uba
que no llegan a ser un estallido social
porque no tiene las dimensiones
exteriores sociales que han sido
magnificadas y coordinadas desde redes
sociales que tienen una clara injerencia
estadounidense en los asuntos internos
de cuba y bueno lo que hemos visto en
las redes es que están no ha satisfecho
las expectativas que tenían quienes lo
han estado organizando desde el exterior
sobre se han visto combinadas a utilizar
una serie de sheikh en imágenes que han
corrido pues por las redes o sea para
fernanda dónde están esas pruebas que
evidencien que éstos se han gestado por
eeuu por el exilio cubano a través de
las redes sociales en donde está eso que
sea evidente
bueno eso lo ha presentado en rueda de
prensa de hecho lo presentó tanto la
cancillería de cuba y el canciller bruno
rodríguez estuvo dando en rueda de
prensa del día de ayer que pues muy bien
revisar y ofrecer
a la audiencia del programa donde
incluso se dan los datos de origen
exactamente donde están anclados esos
bots que hoy día son una herramienta
pues muy usual tanto para lo comercial
como para lo militar dentro del uso de
las redes sociales entonces eso eso está
ahí pero además están los elementos
geopolíticos e históricos que nos dejan
claro que esta acción que se ha
coordinado en cuba se da también en el
mismo momento en que se han coordinado
acciones contra nicaragua contra
venezuela e incluso se realizó una
operación que podríamos llamar de
reordenamiento en haití todo esto
ocurrió en el mismo transcurso de 15
días justamente posterior a la visita
del director de la cia a colombia y
otras autoridades estadounidenses
retomamos la conexión con maría en san
juan en puerto rico- maría a su opinión
sobre estos puntos que nos da maría
fernanda desde caracas que sea
un gran operativo gestado desde
washington desde la casa blanca a través
de las redes sociales que lo que busca
es generar inestabilidad
y allí en la isla en el caribe en cuba
charla completamente recibimos un
problema técnico pero me estoy de
memoria es historia y no es de ahora o
sea hubo históricamente ha culpado por
todo a las prestaciones económicas de
eeuu equipo esto bloqueo y aquí en
realidad no como ustedes vieron no
habían alguien las calles gritando bajo
europeo abajo en embargo lo que estaban
buscando y gritando la libertad al bajo
el comunismo ya no tenemos miedo y esto
no que la acción coordinada el estudioso
porque tuvo destrozado entre tacto
gritos agentes y colaboradores todos
saben interpretar lo que ellos han hecho
y organizado en latinoamérica durante
seis décadas que son estas acciones
clandestinas coordinadas que han vivido
los estados de de la sesión por seis
décadas y que y que en realidad y han
sido planificadas se ve que está más
posible en cuba porque cuba tiene un
estado estalinista con una vigilancia
enorme que no permite que tiene los
grupos los pequeños grupos disidentes y
cifrados y los que no están en las
acciones están muertos no se tienen
entonces esto en cuba no es posible y el
gobierno sólo tiene que volver a la
vieja excusa del embarque por lo demás
llena de mentiras que nada más que el
que tomar las ventas en eeuu para ver
que los insumos médicos las medicinas
los equipos médicos los equipos
agrícolas todo lo que es comida no está
en el el barrio y que además la mayor
ayuda tiene llega a cuba viene de los
estados unidos de la vía ahora se suma
aproximadamente 6 mil millones de
dólares es vélez así existen está
nuestra real al año entonces esto está
está expresa del embargo es absurda y el
muy es el hito de esta fabricación que
cuba se ha dedicado constante a
propaganda a hacer promover en el mundo
la desarticulado el mismo pueblo cubano
que salió y ustedes lo han visto o sea
esto no es una creación del exilio
cubano de de quien sea
así lo vieron ustedes esto tiene un
poder que haciendo un masterado
estratégico que no puedo decir que el
ambiente se ha gestado no desde eeuu
área es impresionante ver a los cubanos
salir a las calles simplemente a
protestar algo que prácticamente no se
veía allí precisamente por la gran
presión que hay por parte del gobierno y
de las fuerzas de seguridad para
contener este tipo de acciones y estos
derechos normales para el mundo
occidental de manifestarse en las calles
y para exigir a los gobiernos de turno
muchos cubanos han dicho a medios
internacionales y personas que han sido
entrevistadas allí en las
manifestaciones que estas marchas
representan un punto de no retorno que
no hay marcha atrás y que precisamente
no compran el discurso el argumento del
embargo ya no es eeuu ese enemigo
evidente evidente que tenían
para la sociedad cubana y que era de lo
que siempre el estado cubano y el
gobierno de los castros se alimentaba
para poder justificar algunas acciones
el gobierno cubano o mejor la sociedad
cubana maría perdió el miedo se acabó
este mito que hay sobre eeuu y sobre
este gran demonio que había en
washington y la casa blanca con el
presidente de turno como lo ve usted
y bueno yo en realidad no soy muy
aficionada a la literatura soy más
aficionada a las ciencias sociales
entonces desde el punto de vista de las
ciencias sociales la historia no es un
mito es una realidad y no se puede hacer
análisis político prescindiendo del
análisis histórico por lo tanto habría
que decir en primer lugar que lo que hay
en cuba lo que ha implementado los eeuu
contra cuba es mucho más que un embargo
es un bloqueo que tiene ya casi 60 años
al cual se opone la asamblea general de
la onu prácticamente en pleno con el
único voto en contra de los eeuu de
israel y que tiene consecuencias claras
en la economía cubana y eso es medible e
incluso econométricamente medibles y es
por ello que incluso países como francia
votará en contra de ese bloqueo año tras
año en la asamblea general de la onu
porque es lo que existe tiene
consecuencias reales en la economía
cubana
y sacarle un lado y pretender analizar
la situación de cuba haciendo borrón de
la historia y haciendo borrón de medidas
coercitivas unilaterales y
extraterritoriales que violan el derecho
internacional de tal envergadura es
tendencioso es pretender hacer
literatura pero bueno a mí me gustan las
ciencias sociales y por eso quiero hacer
el llamado a que se que se valore el
peso real que tiene el bloqueo que es
mucho más que un embargo contra cuba no
es verdad que no repercute en los
alimentos en las medicinas y lo hace
porque hay un bloqueo que impide además
por cierto también las remesas que antes
llegaban desde los eeuu ya pero también
ha impedido la entrada de medicinas en
este caso actualmente de jeringuillas
inyectadoras este se impide también el
llegado la llegada de barcos con
alimentos es decir que ese bloqueo si
tiene claras consecuencias ahora otra
cosa que me gustaría señalar santiago si
me lo permiten
en cuba una protesta el día domingo que
en algunos lugares tuvieron eco el día
lunes pero eso no marca ni un estallido
social ni una crisis verdaderamente
histórica o una crisis orgánica
podríamos decir en términos sociológicos
como por ejemplo si lo marcan dos meses
de paro en colombia de protestas
continuadas de la gente en las calles lo
otro es que han sido muy mediatizada la
protesta de algunos sectores que insisto
están siendo convocados desde miami
hemos visto la imagen de con fusiles
desde miami haciendo llamamiento a la
lucha armada en cuba porque ha sido muy
mediatizado pero no se ha mediatizado no
se ha cubierto incluso se han usado las
imágenes del pueblo que ha salido a
defender la revolución cubana y ese
pueblo también existe también está ahí
ese pueblo revolucionar yo e incluso ese
pueblo que sobre todo lo quiere
se respeta la soberanía de uva entonces
eso también hay que verlo y eso me
permito contradecir no creo que esto
genere una crisis orgánica en la
historia de cuba que por supuesto de
todos
es importante como no lo que está
pasando y por eso estamos aquí
maría fernanda pero llama mucho la
atención ver las imágenes de todas
maneras de los cubanos en las calles
cuando se sabe que el gobierno de este
país reprime a todo tipo de críticas y
de confrontaciones en cuanto a las
medidas que tomaba entonces tal vez por
eso puede ser esa la respuesta y que
llame tanto la atención de la comunidad
internacional ver esas imágenes ver a
los cubanos en las calles porque
anteriormente no era algo común ver a
los cubanos criticando y exigiéndole al
gobierno mejores condiciones alimentos
no más en recortes de luz vacunación y
un plan económico que saque el país del
problema en el que está
desde todos los frentes voy ahora con
maria en san juan para preguntarle a
este país ha estado viviendo una serie
de cambios políticos desde que el
presidente miguel díaz canel asumió allí
la jefatura del gobierno no han dado los
resultados esperados hablo de cambios y
de medidas como por ejemplo el cambio en
cuanto a la liberación de la moneda y
eliminar el peso convertibles dejar
solamente la moneda el peso cubano de
circulación normal en cambio no quiero
ser redundante pero una reforma cambiar
y acelerar la palabra se me escapa la
palabra reforma esto no ha dado
resultado en la economía cubana no ha
podido despegar en lo absoluto porque la
economía cubana viene desde el principio
de la revolución en un declive constante
desde que poca productividad o sea la
planificación central socialista desde
el principio que el fracaso quedar un
país que se alimentaba que noté que
tenía los indicadores socioeconómicos y
buscando
académicos como maría fernanda están en
los libros de las naciones unidas los
principales indicadores económicos y
salen en todo tipo de cosas yo tenía
cuando llegó la revolución al poder
inmediatamente empezaron a acabar con la
producción y el único bloqueo que
existen tú vas real es del gobierno
contra sus propios ciudadanos que no les
permite pensar que no les permite
cosechar que no les permite entrar y
salir libremente que no les permite
tener un negocio o tener una empresa de
la personalidad jurídica etcétera que de
aquel país totalitario es una dictadura
totalitaria unipartidista y comunista y
le hace a la constitución donde los
únicos derechos que se reconocen a los
comunistas no o sea el ciudadano no
tiene derechos y económicos y sociales y
culturales y políticos entonces muchos
académicos que yo conozco en muchos
países no sólo latinoamericanos sino de
eeuu y demás
en tu libro
estudian cuba viajan a cuba lo hacen con
privilegios
yo nunca encontrado o un académico de
ninguna parte que viva cómo viven los
cubanos que vivan así efectividad es que
viven los cubanos que se le están
cayendo las viviendas estila esto no
viene del comité cordiales y creciendo
cuba está en bancarrota bancas locas
bancarrota pública desde 1986 han
recibido decenas de libras y de misiones
de préstamos incluyendo los muchísimos
países capitalistas que no pagan porque
simplemente una economía parásito que
primero dependió de la unión soviética y
luego desde la escuela y ahora implantar
su modelo en venezuela y acabar con esta
economía ya no tiene como escribirla y
se provoca esta crisis agravada por la
la pandemia y el cierre del turismo y
demás tú y eso para mí esto no tiene
vuelta porque no sólo es que la gente
perdió el miedo porque ya no tiene nada
más que perder ahora mismo hay una ola
de terror en cuba están desapareciendo
personas en transmitir casas de noche
matando gente delante decisivos civiles
indefensos y desarmados para reprimir
pero el gobierno no puede recibir a todo
el mundo en todo lugar con el tiempo y
mantener este aparato represivo que está
mucho y ya no hay nada para hacer
partidos y es cuestión de tiempo que
este paciente terminal expire vamos a
ver cuánto cuando viene esto pero el
único bloqueo es el la mafia gobernantes
urbana que es el puesto y le ha negado
la soberanía al pueblo que es donde
pertenece si fuera tan
humanitario y les importará tanto
europeo
simplemente llevarían el país a una
democracia que es lo que exige la ley
americana del congreso sé que sólo
permite levantar las funciones
económicas que hay una transición hacia
una democracia y cuba si el bloqueo o el
embargo las sanciones es la causa de
problemas cuando hay problema pues
entonces democratista en el país para
que levanten el bloqueo pero como en un
estado parásitos
el depor llegaba a dependido de los
demás
maría fernanda en cada caso
bueno comenzar por el final por la
última parte con quién estaba hablando
no solamente conozco cuba conozco
escuela conozco colombia también antes
de conocer cuba conocí los eeuu tuve
oportunidad incluso de vivir en los eeuu
y si hay un estado que vigila a sus
ciudadanos es justamente en los eeuu no
es así el sistema cubano creo que hay
muchos eso sí son mitos sobre la
realidad cubana que además pretenden
decir que en cuba hay una dictadura lo
cual es tan falso como decir que en eeuu
hay una democracia plena
por otro lado la crisis económica es
mundial no solamente es cubana hay una
crisis del capitalismo que se generó en
el 2008 2009 de cuál es el sistema
mundial no se ha recuperado y que la
pandemia lo ha agudizado se han
agudizado los niveles de exclusión y aún
en los países del norte del llamado
primer mundo se han dado muchas
protestas y hay mucho descontento en la
población porque evidentemente con la
pandemia se ha generado una situación
económica muy difícil para el 99 y algo
por ciento de la población mundial lo
que decir es que en cuba por el
contrario hay un gran manejo de la
pandemia y si hay muchos derechos muy
grandes a dos como el derecho a la salud
y el derecho a la educación que empieza
en cuba pues ya quisiéramos que se
garantizar en otros países incluyendo
algunos países del primer mundo como los
de eeuu que no pudieron tener un man de
un manejo de la pandemia que fuera
realmente digno y que tan siquiera se
asemejará a los éxitos
y el manejo en cuba y también en
venezuela tema al que podemos hablar en
otra ocasión porque mi contractura se
menciona pero no es así a fernanda pero
entonces el gobierno cubano es parte de
la solución de este problema cuando van
a asumir desde el gobierno en la habana
la responsabilidad de estar gobernando
en los últimos 60 años en este país y
asumir que en algunos casos han tomado
decisiones que no le han convenido al
país y sobre todo no le han convenido a
los cubanos porque siempre es culpa de
eeuu siempre es culpa el embargo siempre
es culpa de la comunidad internacional
cuando el gobierno de cuba va a sumar a
asumir la responsabilidad de llevar 60
años en este país en las condiciones en
las que viven los cubanos
correcto lo uno noriega lo otro es decir
ciertamente él tiene una presión desde
los eeuu que la propia contertuliano ha
señalado al punto de creer los eeuu que
tiene derecho a exigir un capital de
cuba para terminar con esas medidas
positivas unilaterales y
extraterritoriales que son el bloqueo
pero a pesar de esa realidad la
revolución por supuesto como toda regla
es un proceso de continuidad es muy
importante la autocrítica yo creo que
ciertamente -entre cuba está viviendo un
momento muy difícil quizás el más
difícil en los últimos tiempos porque se
ha agudizado todas las consecuencias del
bloqueo con la situación del pertenencia
con las resoluciones más de 200
resoluciones que de ahorcamiento que
tomaban al trono y que ryder no ha
revertido ya entonces se ha estrenado ya
una autocrítica tomaron medidas que por
cierto este mismo medio hoy mismo estuvo
reseñando y ya desde que se inició la
tarea de ordenamiento a principios de
este año se planteó que se iba a ir
corrigiendo sobre la marcha todas las
posibles consecuencias negativas que
esto tuviera en la población de modo que
la agresión imperialista permanece y sus
consecuencias son innegables son
econométricamente medibles
también son militarmente incluso
evaluables
a pesar de eso la revolución no deja de
ser autocrítica y es así como debe
continuar siendo de seguir auto
criticándose y corrigiendo en lo que se
haya fallado sin lugar a dudas
mariah en la ciudad de san juan en
puerto rico ha sido muy importante el
papel de los jóvenes cubanos en estas
marchas que han tenido lugar en
diferentes ciudades de la isla que
representa que estos movimientos venga
precisamente los jóvenes sean en muchos
casos convocadas a través de las redes
sociales precisamente fue lo primero que
decidió el gobierno fue apagar el
servicio internet para toda la isla para
evitar que las personas estuvieran
conectadas o pudieran difundir
información o recibir información cómo
ve usted el papel de los jóvenes allí en
la isla
los jóvenes de cuba no creen en nada de
esta vía traba imperialista ni nada de
esto me dice tetera como le digo invito
a personas como maría fernanda a ir si a
mí me dejaran entrar que me prohíben la
entrada podríamos ir a visitar las
clínicas los hospitales no los que están
para enseñarle a los extranjeros las 14
instalaciones para cobrarle que el
dólares sino los que tienes dejar el
pueblo esto es lo que está viendo todos
los jóvenes
los cubanos los que están los que
contienen el desayuno la noche y la
comida cómo [__] un bus tener agua o
sea los básicos que este gobierno no
puede garantizar y el problema de eso es
que los jóvenes te dan cuenta que todo
este aparataje ideológico el que ellos
se arroparon con la revolución no sirve
de nada porque el capitalismo más trazo
que es para los jerarcas con sus
barrigas y de 322 mansiones no les llega
al pueblo que se le derrumba las casas
encima esto que eso es lo que han visto
los jóvenes es la única realidad que
conocen la reflexión la falta de
oportunidades la falta de sueño y lo que
quiere es cubano es oliver porque
curiosamente maría fernanda yo no veo a
los americanos viendo para que un guau a
los colombianos con los venezolanos en
falta o como sea llegando a cuba está
entre ves electores a los bebés lo de
las protestas lo de las demostraciones
está como ustedes no son sólo los
jóvenes hay gente de todas las pega del
país de todas las razas
mujeres de hombres de todo o sea en
realidad es expresar de piernas y manos
ahora los académicos y la izquierda que
a un paro tan gobierno totalitario y
criminal que en realidad es fascista con
una cara de comunista pero esto es todo
puro fascismo que van a decir se ya le
doy la palabra maría fernanda sigo con
mariah le hago la pregunta sobre la
posición que ha adoptado eeuu hay temor
en la florida ante la llegada masiva a
una migración masiva desde la isla como
sucedió en 1994
eeuu ya le está prestando un poco más de
atención ya ha dicho incluso que está
dispuesto a enviar lotes de vacunas
contra el cob y 19 para que sean
inoculadas allí en la población cubana
también que si bien se ha desentendido
de la organización de las
manifestaciones se ha mostrado
preocupado por la situación que se está
viviendo allí qué medidas puede tomar el
presidente joe biden para hacer frente a
esta situación
mariah
y también qué medidas puede tomar ese
siguiente iovine primero muy importante
hacer lo que están haciendo algunas de
la necesidad de una transición pacífica
a la democracia que el pueblo pueda
expresarse y lograr si tuvieran y así
que les pongan un modelo económico o
político y demás
en segundo lugar asegurarse que la ayuda
humanitaria llegue directamente al
pueblo no es cierto que estados unidos
corto las remesas activas lo que eeuu
hizo que no vamos a permitir que este
conglomerado militar que se queda de
plano con 10 por ciento de lo que se
mande y scott hace que las personas
hagan un cambio una moneda que no puedo
mostrar que le llegue a la gente o sea
este tipo de cosas de que llegue la
ayuda directa es muy importante y además
lograr que otros países que se han hecho
de la vista gorda
de estos crímenes que se han cometido
consistentemente sistemáticamente contra
el color humano se termina sin comidas y
se exige para continuar tratando a jugar
como un estado de la comunidad
internacional que se comporte como tal y
permita una elección libre periodista
pública turismo permita la libertad de
expresión y la asociación del movimiento
etcétera todas las libertades
universalmente reconocidas que se le han
llegado a este pueblo maria fernanda que
se puede decir de esos vídeos que han
circulado a través de las redes sociales
que han publicado los mismos ciudadanos
cubanos donde se ve a las fuerzas de
seguridad golpeando a los manifestantes
las denuncias que hay de gente de la
policía cubana entrando a las casas
golpeando atacando y arrestando sin
ningún tipo de argumento a algunos
ciudadanos por simplemente haber salido
a manifestarse allí en las calles de
diferentes ciudades qué opinión tiene
usted
bueno soy bastante acuciosa cuando
accede a las redes sociales porque sé
que hay una saturación de información de
hecho antes de tu programa estaba
escuchando precisamente en este canal
como hay una saturación de información y
de lo que llaman ahora fake news en las
redes sociales
hasta ahora todos los vídeos que hemos
visto que no respondan al al uso
proporcionado y diferenciados de la
fuerza que ha hecho la policía cubana
que no está ni cerca de parecerse por
ejemplo a la represión que se vivió en
colombia en estos dos últimos meses o en
francia contaron los chalecos amarillos
sino que ha sido una represión como te
digo proporcionada y diferencia este
hasta ahora todos los vídeos que hemos
visto han sido of fate ya o incluso han
utilizado imágenes como te dije de gente
que sale a protestar a favor de la
revolución
para ponerla como si fueran personas que
están protestando contra la revolución
entonces las redes sociales bastan para
saber que están siendo manipuladas
por ejemplo la cantidad de trinos que se
emiten en un segundo y eso sólo se puede
hacerse a través de bots con respecto a
la migración yo quería decir por cierto
porque la contertulia mencionó la
ministra
bueno la migración es uno de mis temas
colombia continúa siendo según la
organización internacional de las
migraciones del país con mayor número de
emigrantes de todo el continente
americano no es cuba no es venezuela
simplemente hay una politización sobre
esa migración un uso político de esa
migración y lo otro que quería decir es
que yo conozco cuba no la conozco desde
afuera no la conozco
aunque turís
bueno perdimos la conexión con varias
bandas pero igual llegamos al final del
programa maría maría fernanda en caracas
y en san juan les agradezco mucho haber
estado con nosotros aquí en el debate
haber expuesto sus puntos de vista sobre
este tema sobre la situación que se está
presentando en cuba'
muchas gracias por haber compartido con
nosotros y ustedes pueden seguir dejando
sus opiniones en la encuesta en línea a
través de las redes sociales sigan con
nosotros
[Música]